on the mound today for the cubs kid's
got a good arm
slider two seamer four seamer a change
up in a curveball
he pumps it up there about uh 93-94 this
is his
tenth start really good numbers in the
49 two-thirds innings points only
getting 200
he's a strike thrower as well that's a
pretty good look here comes the one-two
to tommy pham
swinging a miss that didn't take long
first strike out of the day for
alzheimer's
but shadow goes that one is bounced
over the mound and fielded by wisdom
inside corner froze him hosmer is gone
alzalei strikes out the first baseman to
end the inning
on the hill for the padres is danel
sidleman 28 year old making his fifth
start
third career outing versus the cub first
at wrigley
and as i mentioned earlier in our game
open keep the ball in the ballpark
there's that there you go there's the
slider and he strikes him out with it
for the first out
getting knocked down by that win 98 and
by him
strike shot by his back-to-back case for
lament two down
they survived it here's the 1-0 and that
is a hard hit grounder right at air
cosmo down to one knees got it near the
bag steps on first
and the inning is over
rizzo ranging to his right house gets
over
steps on the base and that is out number
one
3-1 to kim fly ball right center
converging our hap and ortega
and hat makes the catch
slider outside corner got him malzali
will skip off the mound
he has struck out three today we're
midway in the second
lou gehrig day around major league ball
as rafael ortega steps in
he lines the bases into left field over
toward the line is fam to backhand the
ball
ortega with a one out single
[Applause]
swing and a miss and sogard strikes
south third k for lumet
to short kim to his left he'll throw out
higgins and that'll end the second
inning
he's a great human being here's a big
chop
left side bios will glove it and come up
throwing to first that's in time to get
rivas it's out number one
swinging a miss by lee lumet and it's a
strikeout for ad barrett alzheimer he's
rolling along
swinging a miss strike three and elsa
rolling along
strike three call also i knew it takes
with him the fourth strikeout for
danelle schulman
so far by lumet and a swing of minutes
they're in a pitch in the dirt
there's a slider in the dirt and they
gotta throw him out and they do
line it picked connor worth laying it
out on an exploding hop at second base
cronoworth says no
what a play by jake crawdenworth
manny machado hits a high fly ball
playable shallow right center
hap and ortega there ortega a handful of
als charities
that's in the air out to center half
has it runners on first and second two
outs
and ha kim coming up
to center and a base hit they're gonna
send cronenworth around
the throw will go to second and the
padres take a one-nothing lead
a two-out rbi single for ha sung kim
puts the padres on top one to nothing
swinging a miss strikes him out on a
slider this time baez has gone down
twice against lumet
runner goal checks ring base head right
field
rizzo's not stopping he ends up at third
that's the way it's going right now for
patrick wisdom
enjoy first and third one away ortega
the batter
1-1 ortega hits a big chop slowly toward
first
miso will score the throw to first not
in time
everybody is safe four game tied at one
hosmer bobbled the ball he was gonna
throw
home never got the handle and as a
result
he got nobody that'll be
ball game tied at one a run in
base is loaded with one away dj higgins
the batter
[Applause]
in the air shallow going out kim out
some more
look out and they collide tagging and
scoring from third is patrick wisdom and
fam and kim
are down look at the ball pops out
and so the ball came back into the
infield and with everybody advancing
we're not advancing so there's a force
play here out number two
so this that's that's what happened the
runners on first and second
did not try to advance because they said
they saw it as a catch
and then a throw back in yes so it's a
double play
kim doesn't look good tommy pham got hit
hard
let me family he's coming off under his
own power he just looks mad yeah
so both kim and pham coming out of this
game
that one's too high somebody just got
tossed
the padres pitching coach larry
rothschild has been thrown out of the
game
oh boy anthony rizzo entered today's
ball game hitting
370 against left-handed pitching
let's see if he can give the cubs the
lead
in the air slicing profile can't get it
and two runs are going to score jack is
in and it is
3-1 high steppen rizz loves it with two
on and two out
for left fielder jorge mateo here at the
top of the seventh inning
chopped to the right side alcantara
handles and he gets out of it
good job by tommy nance
[Applause]
a swing and a smash past hosmer it's
gonna end up in the right field corner
alcontra has great speed racing around
second
flying into third here comes the throw
in it's a triple
and listen to this crowd here is ian
happ
the infield remains in with one away
amp hits the ground ball now alcantara
will try to score he will score
the ball bobbled by cronenworth hubs
lead 4-1
cubs four san diego one runner on first
one at javi baez
here's the 2-2 hammered left field on a
line got a chance gone
an absolute rocket to left field
and things have opened up on his 14th
and it is
6-1
in the air and this should do it ortega
wandering over
under it he's got it cubs win
they sweep the padres